hi I'm Ryan Wright and I'm Jerry and I'm
Caroline Mitchell welcome to our show
called four reasons to say why don't we
give you reasons to see not to see dumb
games catching fire let's hang out
reason to see number one Jennifer
Lawrence Martin Lawrence is so good
Martin Lawrence is hilarious in this
month you just said Jennifer Lawrence by
hi - okay
so Jennifer Lawrence though man she okay
not only if she gets a look at she's
[ __ ] talented as ever I loved her and
this more than the first one I think
first of all why did they dye her hair
in this one and if they wanted to it
maybe shed a different hair color they
should have dyed it back to the original
color but she's they had a weighted
elite ish now so she's probably been
printing [ __ ] it still lives in a shack
what you talking about was a shack there
was like a two-story house she lives in
Wow yeah the problems you find with
films alright okay I don't like how she
cries in the film at all it's like
really I don't like this face it makes
me want to hit her every time and she
cries a lot I'm gonna bring it down from
up to uh it's like way better everybody
looks a little silly when they get room
what were there really crimes for Hannah
and I'm sure you look at when you cry
but okay you know like 80% of people
look silly when they cry you're the
other 20% I'm in the twenty yeah
whatever she does a great job
first reason to see it release good to
see number two Josh Hutcherson a lot of
people don't like you know talk about
this guy's performance but I think it
does a really good job like the dude has
a lot of internal struggles the die has
to deal with he's got this girl Louise
in love with who who just wants to put
on an act you know and he's it's a great
job he's charming and stuff yep he's
very charming
I feel bad for him he's friendzone real
hard oh yeah yeah that's like like
harder than anyone has been friend-zoned
to ever before yeah but no I like him a
lot in this movie and you know it's like
the first one it's like yeah he's there
he does a good job but this one I was
like okay
I see why you got this job I mean he's
always he's done a great job since he
was little like little Manhattan he's
always been acting I think he's good
Caroline has been following this guy's
career for years reasons to see number
three Woody Harrelson
my favorite I love Haymitch I love that
he's a drunk yeah nothing Jerome I do
like the parallel that he already knows
what Katniss is just finding out that
the real world once you win this game
you figure out what [ __ ] everyone
are and that's why he's an alcoholic I
feel like that's his way of coping and
she's gonna change the game yeah he
could feel like this guy has a lot of
trauma behind everything you know and
he's just constantly an escapism add a
moody harrelson though you could make
the guy funny at the same time it brings
a lot of life to the character every
time he shows up on screen you're like
oh I'm glad you're here I'm glad you
made it woody liked how they the other
two previous winners were like meth
heads now yeah and then there was
another couple of winners that were also
alcoholic yeah apparently alcoholics is
the thing in the future no weed though
no weed well let's face it all these
people would be happier if they all
smoked weed reason to see number four
the directing and cinematography the
first ones were a handheld very close to
this one it's much smoother and it the
whole time dude like that even the
action was I thought improved way more
all of it was is captured so brilliantly
I loved the tone and everything I agree
no yeah and I mean it seeing it on
IMAX's is incredible they really shoot
the whole game portion of this movie is
shot in complete IMAX that goes all the
way up and it's pretty overwhelming yeah
I did not see it in IMAX or 3d or
anything and I could tell that it was
shocked for 3d and it kind of messes
with you whatever you want to see it in
IMAX when you're looking at it
it looks terrible reason is Z number
five writing
I like the characters a lot in this film
you know like the writing of them what I
thought was really good all of them are
very three-dimensional the interactions
between all of them is very good I love
the way all the events unfold the
reveals the twists the turns the first
one was really just kind of an
introduction to this world and now
here's the real [ __ ] that's going on
like you beat up the Hunger Games world
is big this takes in the first one this
takes you to like a much bigger scope of
things man it takes you to like the
whole behind the scenes of every yeah
you get to see more of the capital and
you get to see different parts of
district 12 and you get to see a lot of
different things so your scope of where
they are and the drama is intense like
everything just intensifies way more
it's dark man it's dark villains a bleak
movie I feel like the title should have
been like The Hunger Games no more
[ __ ] around reason to see number six
Liam Hemsworth these Hemsworth brothers
are sexy as [ __ ] they are he's kind of
sexy
oh he well I think Christmas are more
superior the sexy department but he's
sexy for an oppressed district 12
Brook coal miner he is pretty fun er his
hair always looks good no matter how
much work the guy does but liam
hemsworth yeah they gave him more screen
time much more disappointed last movie
when I saw Oh Liam Hemsworth is gonna be
in it and he had but two scenes in this
movie you see a lot more Liam Hemsworth
he's more important in this one you know
yeah he has much more of an expect plays
more of a role you see more interaction
with him in Katniss bringing on the
romance the love triangle thing going on
I like it reason to see number seven the
visual effects this world goes a lot
bigger and so they have to use like way
more visual effects this time around and
I thought it was all pretty [ __ ] cool
it was pretty seamless none of it looked
fake it was all believable visual
effects you have to see a bigger scope
of the things like the arena for the
Hunger Games this time is far larger
far more dense there's more things
everywhere they're not just walking
around a jungle you can tell they had to
animate everything from top to bottom
there were a couple moments like you
know there's a set piece that involves
gorillas like creatures and they looked
little CG ish to me not like sci-fi
channel but you know still it was like
okay those are clearly effects I'm
pretty sure there are pathogens but yeah
yeah not gorillas Jerry
none of the animals in the whole
document Oh the fog I don't know I mean
I love the way the thought looked I like
their reaction it gave off I'm not gonna
tell you what happened
but it kind of just reminded me of an
old cheesy horror film not the way it
looked just that they were scared of the
fog that wasn't just a fog yeah actually
that scenes are really good I'm just
saying it didn't it was a little bit
he'll give me that yeah it was the
reason to scene every production design
the costumes again like the last movie
were phenomenal phenomenal but comical
at the same time district one are so
ridiculously lavished out you got like
lavish things and you gotta like the
actual Hunger Games and you got like
really poor areas it all seems like it's
all part of the same world at the same
time you hear explaining like very
different areas at all together man it's
it's really impressive the art design
was great assets were [ __ ] awesome I
love the whole Hunger Games sequence
well it seems like it would have been a
blast to work on for those people like
it must be a dream for the people
earnest costumers and dressers amazing
and dream come true I love what they did
with all the costumes there's many more
this time Effie it wears a lot more
outfits this time but you see a
diversity she's not as white this time -
she's pretty white reasons to see number
9 this score this music just moves you
man it's like speed just adds to the
cinematic experience
I just love intense cinematic music have
you ever worked out - cinematic music no
it's [ __ ] awesome do you feel like
you're part of a movie the whole time
and you're working out like never before
in different movies I really appreciate
some of the scores and they move
mien and they stay in my head and like
everybody remembers scores from Lord of
the Rings and from Star Wars and this is
not just such a really strong movie for
a score so I wouldn't say that's a
reason to go they didn't do wrong there
by any means but it's not our reason to
go in my opinion in their opinion in his
reason to see number 10 Donald
Sutherland
I liked him way more than this in the
first one the first one he doesn't do
like anything and this one like he is
the antagonist of the film and he's a
good antagonist you know he is have a
devilish kind of president W guy going
on he is the push for the oppressing and
you can tell well just like all the
other characters like I mentioned with
Effie you start to see more in depth he
was in a few scenes in the last movie
and he just kind of waved his fingers
and people did what he said or did it
and got killed but in this movie you see
him with a much more forceful hand he's
on top of it he's making sure nobody's
[ __ ] around like the last time reason
to see number 11 Philip Seymour Hoffman
I love him I honestly did not know he
was gonna be in the movie when I went to
go see it and I was so happy when I saw
him he plays the perfect role I can't
tell you if he's I can't tell you I love
watching him in like everything because
it was fun to watch but he's also subtle
and real at the same time he's got kind
of that devilish charm that when I love
her yeah stealth badges telleth badge oh
yeah I thought he was a great addition
to this world and I'm glad to see him
part of this cast man because he's gonna
you know yeah I think in part 300 duty
waits in well you see he's gonna
continue into the third movie and that's
gonna be a reason to see number three
for me right there reason to see number
12 Jena Malone have you guys ever seen
stepmom like I don't know um two years
ago Julia Roberts snow-blowing Sigourney
Weaver is I'm messing up there no it's
Julia Roberts and Susan Sarandon you
just follow the code
so anyway I loved her in that she plays
the same spunky little [ __ ] as she did
in step mom and she's like [ __ ] all of
you [ __ ] your rules [ __ ] this [ __ ] that
I [ __ ] love her oh and she has an
implied nude scene yeah really hot it
was where Katniss gets [ __ ] chillin
it's cool to have a character like that
the one who's just like standing out of
amongst the hide oh you little [ __ ] not
for herself and not for the better of
mankind just literally doesn't care
she's not trying to change the world
issues well in a sneaky way they don't
know that yet that will spoil alert Oh
anyway we got awkward in here reason to
see number 13 but in it I like this dude
man at first I was like great another
annoying cocky douche Banarasi on-screen
is probably gonna be a two-dimensional
performance but he ended up being more
human and I ended up really liking the
guy a lot yeah he looks like one of
those Carrefour marble douche bag God
like looking characters who probably
doesn't wipe his own ass and then you
end up falling for the guy reason to see
number 14 the rest of the tributes I
thought it was cool how like then the
Hunger Games are pairing up a bunch of
like former Hunger Games winners
together yeah so you get to see a lot
more intellect involved and stuff like
that not so much from the opposing team
but a lot from the crew that you're
hanging out with the whole time in this
Hunger Games as opposed to everybody
just being badasses who can [ __ ]
sharpen knives and throw them at lizards
and blah blah blah this time you see
more of the people like in rougarou up
this is who rue would be she would be
one of those smart can hide in a [ __ ]
tree make gadgets you see those kind of
tributes not just the strong and then
the little ones who hang out with the
strong ones you see everybody is strong
for different reasons this time everyone
has their own special set of skills yeah
everybody in there is a badass and they
are fine-tuned so it's much more
interesting to watch also I want to add
there's a lot more death in this one and
it's great but also even just a casting
of those people because I don't yeah
it's a bunch of people who you're like
you don't know their names will you keep
seeing and you're like oh that guy or
that
who looks kind of weird Ryan's Consensus
The Hunger Games Catching Fire is the
reason movies are made The Hunger Games
Catching Fire is the reason movies are
made yeah like this to me was like this
is why I love going to the theaters
Jerry's Consensus a dark authentic
sequel is the reason to see the Hunger
Games Catching Fire a dark off that
sequel is the reason to see Hunger Games
Catching Fire ya know like I really dug
this one like I like the first one and
this one you know was even better
Caroline's consensus there are a lot of
reasons to see the Hunger Games Catching
Fire there are a lot of reasons to see
the Hunger Games Catching Fire I'm
talking my favorite to the actors and
the costumes and the expansion on where
they go in the world this time alright
guys he's checking out a review for the
Hunger Games Catching Fire let's go
ahead and stole that comment box will
that one tell us which one did you like
more first one the second one and why
once you're done with that if you want
to see more episodes the reason to see
come over here and click this button and
last but not least if you want to get
updated every time a new review or a
video is out so click on Keralites you
subscribe and we can put a link right
here to check out her photo right here
yeah man if you think she's pretty to
look at now you should see these photos
where she's happening get Holy Mother of
God it is something else
she is toned it works out I work out
yeah that's what she said
yes teachers and she gets great out work
out some the moons have spikes oh yeah
I learn that firsthand just now yeah but
I see like I've seen a lot of her photos
there are a lot on my computer and I
have a little slideshow I just watch
every morning and every night helps me
go - trust me
first it keeps me up all night without
some staff like 15 extra minutes and
then you yeah been about five minutes of
intensity yeah
so it's really